In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 12th, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyrs,
Proklaus and Hilary.
Emperor Trajan decreed that all who refused to sacrifice to idols and declared themselves
Christians would be condemned to die by fire in about the year 112.
Others were sent around the Empire to denounce their friends, brothers or children in the hopes
of some miserable recompense.
Others denounced Christians through fear of the Emperor or through zeal for paganism.
Some decided to travel to the region of Ankara in Galatia to smoke out the Christians and
hand them over to Maximus the Governor.
They arrested a certain Proklaus who lived in the village of Kalipus near Ankara and took
him to the city where the Emperor was in residence.
As he was being taken to the tribunal, bound with chains, Proklaus sang, direct my steps,
Lord, in the way of peace, and open my lips to proclaim thy praise.
When being commanded by the Emperor to sacrifice under pain of being delivered to the beasts,
he replied, The Lord is my helper.
I shall not fear what man can do to me.
Grinding his teeth with rage, the Emperor had him taken back to the prison.
Three days later, the Governor summoned him for interrogation, but as the Holy Martyr replied
fearlessly, he obtained permission from the Emperor to submit him to the worst of tortures.
He summoned him again before him and reminded him that the sacrifices had been ordered by Imperial
Command.
Proklaus retorted, They are wicked laws drawn up according to their own wicked actions.
To insult the Emperor's endearing to criticize the laws they have promulgated for our salvation,
replied Maximus.
When he threatened him, the Saints replied, I am not afraid of your tortures, for it is written.
Do not fear those who kill the body but cannot kill the soul.
Fear God rather than mortal beings.
The Governor then told him to choose what tortures he should undergo.
As the Holy Martyr's only reply was to curse the false gods, the Governor had him stretched
on a rack and beaten mercilessly so that all in the vicinity were splattered with his blood.
And Proklaus uttered neither word nor cry, but when Maximus declared that he was losing
strength and was near death, he said, May God grant that my heart does not fail, and I wander
aside from my God.
Force however to leave with Maximus, who was about to depart for Caliples, the Saint prayed
that the Governor would not be able to move until he confessed the only true God.
Maximus suddenly stopped dead and was unable to move.
Learning from the Saint, the condition on which he would be able to continue his journey,
he took a piece of paper and wrote on it, I confess that the God of Proklaus is the only
true God, and that there is none beside him.
He was then immediately able to continue his journey, yet when he arrived at Caliples, he
summoned Proklaus and accused him of using magic to immobilize him, and thereupon ordered
his officials to seer the Saint's body with flaming torches.
The latter remained unmoved and silent.
They then hanged him on a gibbet, tying a large rock to his feet, and finally took him
away to be executed.
On the way Proklaus came face to face with his nephew, Hilary, who greeted and embraced
him.
And by the soldiers, he declared that he too was a Christian, and so he was immediately
thrown into prison.
Arriving at the place of execution, Proklaus obtained a delay in order to pray, and kneeling
down, asked the Lord that his favor might rest on all those who had recourse to his intercession.
An angel appeared to him, summoning him to receive the victor's crown in heaven, and
thus he consummated his martyrdom on the 12th of April, being pierced to death with arrows.
Hilary was then brought before the governor.
He repeated his declarations and disdained the threat of torture.
After having been beaten, he was dragged along the ground for three miles, while his blood
flowed down on the ground.
He sang the psalm, its foundations rest on the holy mountain.
The Lord loves the gates of Zion more than all the tents of Jacob.
He was finally beheaded on the 7th of July, and his body was buried with that of St. Proklaus.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.